if you had an emergency and needed to
come up with $400 right now could you do
it
shockingly nearly half of Americans said
they couldn't which is another way of
seeing that nearly half of Americans
have no financial flexibility or freedom
while it might not be the flashiest or
most exciting financial goal an
emergency fund is the foundation your
entire financial health is built upon
without it it's just a matter of time
before an unexpected jolt causes a crack
that will eventually bring the whole
house down we recently asked you our
amazing two cents community to share
your real-life stories about how an
emergency fund or lack thereof has
impacted your lives and you really came
through so let's learn from each other
what not having savings is truly costing
you and pick up some tips for finally
making it a reality
[Music]
Rose and her husband were in the
military making decent money as she
finished up college unfortunately they
didn't see any real need to save any of
it so the day Rose was supposed to leave
for a study abroad program her husband
totals their new car on the way to the
airport rendering them both carless and
cashless so what have you found yourself
in a similar situation how much money
could you save by having a proper
emergency fund if your car decides to
kick the bucket I think it's time to run
the numbers
let's assume you are for lack of a
better word average most people when
buying a car buy used with an average
purchase price of twenty thousand eighty
four dollars you've also got the average
American credit score of 673 and what's
the most common car loan length of 72
months running this scenario through a
big named bank gave me an AP our
estimate of seven point nine four
percent that means you'd be potentially
paying a gobsmacking
five thousand dollars an interest alone
over the lifetime of that loan if you or
they had had even a little bit of an
emergency fund you could have
potentially afforded a shorter loan term
gotten a better interest rate or maybe
even skipped out on interest all
together and just bought a cheaper car
in cash all of which could have saved
you hundreds if not thousands of dollars
another common unexpected expense you
guys talked about were house repairs
poor Breanna and her husband woke up on
one of the coldest days in winter with
flames shooting from the back of their
furnace thankfully they had 3500 in
savings to keep frostbite at bay but
what if they had approached it like most
people would and put those repairs on a
credit card treating your credit cards
like an emergency fund is like trying to
use one of those weighted workout vests
as a lifejacket with the average current
credit card interest rate at nineteen
point two four percent financing a vital
repair like that could have cost them an
extra six hundred and seventy three
dollars even if they managed to pay it
off in one year that number could have
easily climbed into the thousands if
they stretched it out over a few years
but the lack of an emergency fund can
cost you more than money after a year of
battling an illness one of our YouTube
community members almost Lindsay ended
up needing an emergency surgery
thankfully she had decent health
insurance so it shouldn't have been a
big deal the problem was she'd already
used up her sick leave at work so the
time she'd be spending in the hospital
would also be no paycheck time without
emergency savings and no access to
credit because of her lack of income she
was forced to beg friend
and family to help recover basics like
rent and food until she could get back
to work she recalled the whole situation
being both stressful and humiliating and
has worked hard to save up a cash
cushion in the time since then there's
Ashley who said having an emergency fund
may have saved her life she had a
suspicion that she might be suffering
from sleep apnea but quickly learned
that the testing and equipment involved
wouldn't come cheap
she said that having her emergency fund
gave her the confidence to schedule an
appointment with her doctor thank
goodness she did
turns out tests showed her hunch was
correct and the lack of oxygen during
sleep had been significantly taxing her
heart thankfully she told us after a
six-month treatment she's doing much
better yeah I'm sure you're thinking I
get it Phillip and Julia I need an
emergency fund but how do I get one here
are our favorite three tips to start
laying down your financial foundation
the right way tip 1 pick a specific
number most experts agree that a fully
funded emergency fund should have
between three and six months of expenses
this number isn't just based on bills
and rent but also flexible expenses like
groceries medications and transportation
that is typically enough to pay
deductibles on your health or auto
insurance and could also potentially
handle a major transition like a sudden
move or a critical home repair tip to
get organized now that you have a
savings target in mind
set your money for this goal apart in
some way if your savings for emergencies
a new phone and your brother's bachelor
party or smashed together in a general
savings bucket you're sabotaging
yourself get clear on what money is for
true emergencies and give it a special
home tip 3 sprint sometimes to get
something you've never had you'll have
to do something you've never done
try challenging yourself to a spending
freeze cut back on every non-essential
expense and hustle for any extra income
you can for just one month seriously
cancel all your subscriptions tell your
friends you're sorry you can't go see
the new Marvel movie and read comics at
the library instead remember it's just
for 30 days see how far you can get
towards your goal then maybe take a week
or two break to catch your breath well
for a nice meal or two then hit it hard
again until you're done now Congrats
you're making it all the way to the end
of the video because we're going to
share a powerful little secret with you
saving up for an emergency fund requires
you to be intentional focused and to
live below your means which are the
exact same financial muscles it takes to
ultimately build well so when you're
finally done with this goal awesome
take those mad money muscles you just
earned and use them to build something
amazing on top of the foundation you've
just laid down and that's our two cents
thanks to our patrons for keeping two
cents financially healthy click the link
in the description if you'd like to
support us on patreon
[Music]